good afternoon and welcome to this joint
standards meeting on the 17th of august
2021
my name is councillor mark bassinger
and i'm the chairman of this committee
could i take this opportunity to welcome
mr mitchell
who's our new independent person this is
his first jsc committee meeting
that's thank you bernie that might be a
good idea perhaps we could all introduce
ourselves to mr mitchell so he has an
idea who we are saying
uh
and of course myself mark bassinger
great i think we have that
before we commence the business of the
meeting there are a few housekeeping
issues to run through
members the setup for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for covid
therefore can i ask all present to work
to the protocol agreed at council on the
29th of april 2021
in the interest of member and officer
safety
we are streaming this meeting live and
as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you're giving
your consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up or raise your
paddle to indicate if you wish to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
when invited to speak please remove your
mask put on your visor turn on your
microphone
and fasten your seat belts and speak
clearly
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the gender
papers
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible and ensure your
microphones remain off when not speaking
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda papers regarding
the different levels within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit is in the
door behind this top table
so item number two apologies for absence
may i have apologies for absence please
bernard thank you chairman we've
received apologies for absence from
councillors juric and jarvis
thank you very much
item number three the minutes
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 22nd of february
2021 found on pages three to eight are
approved as a true and accurate record
i so move do i have a seconder for that
motion
thank you very much
does anyone have any matter of accuracy
yeah so i wasn't at that meeting however
on page six there is a typo
um
and it's
about halfway down the page a debate
ensued uh council stated that a
determination was held at a high
threshold and that comes accountable to
have a prior hearing fewer as very
different to
to determine a predetermination so that
there's it doesn't grammatically as this
as this is a very different
maybe it should read
rather than see we as
so just a typo
and maybe a change of words around i
think councillor siddal thuy is
sanscript you're fine
before
yeah i think we've noted uh that typo i
believe bernard have we yes thank you
yeah thank you very much
are there any other
queries
agreed yep so we can agree those minutes
by sent hopefully agree thank you very
much those minutes are agreed
uh
moving on to
item no we're not we're moving to item
number five which is declarations of
interest and that's for me again
and this is disclosed in the existence
and nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests
other peculiar interests or non-bikini
interests relating to items of business
on the agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
would anyone like to declare any
pecuniary or non-binary interest
and silent
says scent i think so we don't have
anyone
thank you very much moving on to item
number five which is the report
uh the report is a consultation on
complaints process of the articles for
standards arrangements catchy title
um i shall now um ask mr quelch to um
present the report
um and the report could be found on
pages 9 to 16 of the agenda
thank you mr quelch thank you
yeah as as is mentioned in the report
on the 24th of may i'm sure you'll
remember it vividly
i sent round a email to ah okay yeah you
want it thank you
that's it thank you yeah um thank you
chair on the 24th of may
i sent round and all counsellor email
um asking for members views on the
complaints process
to deal with complaints against members
simply because there have been
um
a few members that had raised concern as
to how that operated
and so in agreement with the leader
um it was thought best that um i
canvassed all members
the result of that canvassing is this
report
i had about i think there's about five
members that responded to me and i set
out
uh their responses as they gave them to
me um in the order in which i received
them
at 3.1
and then i give my response to each of
those
um
and they go from a to j
um in 3.2
and some of those responses
result in a change to the
what's known as the article 7 complaints
process that forms a part of the
constitution
and you'll see that i've mentioned four
changes
and my response also to the other
matters from hj
and then if you go to appendix one
of my report you'll see what i've done
is i've reproduced the existing article
7 standard arrangements that forms part
of the constitution
and then i've added in
with track changes
what i
am asking the committee to consider
based on the consultation of members
there are a few other matters that i
haven't mentioned in the report that
weren't the subject of
comment by member
um two met two major matters the first
one is
if you go to appendix one
and you go to
page 15 of the
committee report so it's appendix one
and you'll see there is
a paragraph five under stage one of the
process
and in that you'll see that there are a
number of options available for
for me and for the independent person
to decide how to deal with a complaint
and one of those is you go down to the
fifth bullet point you you'll see it did
read moip decide to put straight to
investigation brackets internal
and then stage two hearing and what i've
done is i've changed that to formal
investigation the real reason for that
is if you remember in the minutes of the
at the last jsc
i was asked to actually
bring a report to
to members here simply because i had
referred
a matter to
jsc
um about investigation and this this
whole matter of
i
the mo and ip can actually
determine there should be a formal
investigation but we can't determine
whether it should be an internal one or
an external one seems to me
very inconsistent
because that's a minor issue the big
issue is should there be an
investigation
and so
um
and then linked with that was also the
issue of
also whether i should
be able to refer a matter to jsc as to
whether there should be an investigation
or not
and you probably will recall i think the
chairman
raised the issue as to the
appropriateness of that which i have to
say i agree with i understand the
reasoning behind that so what i've also
done is you'll see i've removed
one of the final bullet point to remove
my power
to refer a matter as to whether
a complaint should be investigated or
not to jsc
i think the reasoning of the of the
chair he'll correct me if i'm wrong was
very much that this is your territory
jsc should not be deciding issues like
that jfc should be deciding issues
about a final report where there's been
an investigation and then it's for jsc
to say yes there's a breach and then
impose a sanction if there is a breach
and that was the main role of jsc and
other matters like the code of conduct
and how it operates
so hopefully you'll see that and finally
the other matter not mentioned in the
report is
i've added in
right at the end on page 16 of your
papers
the public interest test now some
members that were on jfc last you
remember that that was agreed that there
should be
some criteria for the mo and the ip to
decide whether there should be a formal
investigation
for
looking at it from the public interest
point of view and so what i've done is
i've taken the opportunity of also
adding in
that which has already be determined by
jsc last year into the complaints
process so if any member of the public
wanted to have a look at that they'll
see what the criteria are
that
i and the iep think about
when we decide whether to formally
investigate or not
thank you chair
thank you very much so we've all heard
the report so i shall open that up to
questions and uh counsellor nun please
ah yes
yes thank you very much chair and um
first of all can i thank um mr quelch
for considering the um
suggestions that were submitted to him
um uh in part as part of the
consultation i've got three points that
i'd like to raise please
i don't know if you want me to take them
in turn chair or just
say them all at the moment
let's take them in turn if we okay so my
first point is that under one c
this is appendix one by the way sorry
appendix one one c
uh we're now moving this to
say that the local council member
representatives should be nominated by
malden town and
town i understand the logic behind that
but i have
two subsidiary questions connected to
that first of all
do
does the ealc know about that decision
that change
and secondly uh how will the parishes
feel about that do we think
thank you that's my first question
mr quelch yes it is
i'll remember to do the buttons i'm not
very good at that i confess um
yeah the elc have said to us
actually that they don't want the
nomination
powers
and so i haven't told them
what they said was in fact it is the
malden town council and burnham that in
fact do that i know the mold molten town
count in effect it's a grouping of
councils that get together but i think
modern town council are very much
involved in arranging that
for one part and
so ealc of it having effect said to me
um we don't really want to do this
they've not used those words but it's
been really really hard and i know
councillor stilts will know this
it's been really hard to get nominations
from the elc i have to chase them chase
them chase them and then they come up
with a reason why they can't do it so
it's it's frustration i know the
committee clerks will know that's the
case as well and that's why we only have
one nomination at the moment one nominee
counts to stilts we haven't had a second
one because the elc haven't haven't done
anything about it
as to the second question
um
i haven't gone round or
simply because there are 31 parish
councils or is it 32 now with haybridge
basin
i haven't gone round all of them because
i think it's just far too many and
there'll be so many different views um
and trying to
if one gives my view is if you give a
consultation like that then there's an
expectation that you will actually
listen very very carefully to what
everybody says and i can see there'll be
some very different views on how that
should be arranged so
my reasoning was simply this chair
the mould and town and burnham town
council are the biggest parish councils
they're in different parts of the
district
and um it seems sensible for them to do
the nominating
thank you uh thank you chair and thank
you to mr quelch and mayor suggests
respectfully then chair that um
when we finish this when we've agreed
this document that both the elc and the
parishes are notified particularly as
one of our
previous representatives was from
southminster parish council
um can i move on to my second point
please check i come back
uh yes you may absolutely
uh thank you
i think it's absolutely appalling that
uh we are just saying that it's malden
town council and and burnhamtown council
i think it's absolutely ridiculous
you can't make that sort of decision
my view is that we look for nominations
from parish councils in alphabetical
order
and if a council which doesn't want to
put forward a name then we move on to
the next letter in the alphabet in terms
of that parish council you can't you
can't choose because they're the largest
the two those two town councils is
completely undemocratic and
representation should be from different
parishes across the district
at different times so i think the
recommendation should be that council
members are represented in order as they
are alphabetically we could start from a
and then the middle of the alphabet and
gradually work through
every two years asking parish councils
for nominations if they don't want to
put on the forward nomination we move to
the next letter in the alphabet
that's far more democratic
thank you could i go to councillor maze
please yeah thank you mr chairman
i too am not not very comfortable with
the nominations coming from
moltentown and burnhamtown
on from what councillor siddal has said
i think there needs to be a more
open transparent and democratic way of
dealing with this and perhaps this
should be advertised with all of the
councils
uh parish councils town councils
people are put forward because there
will be people out there who'll be very
keen exactly the same way as we do with
our independent person advert goes out
someone is nominated
and we take it forward with a two-year
post
i think
what is currently written is
not a workable
solution in my view thank you
councillor stilts
thank you mr chairman nearly said mr
mayor um right when the elc called for
the independent uh representative
um it was held at morgantown council
chamber
there was myself there was someone from
haybridge and there was someone from
another um parish
those two weren't interested they'd just
come along to see what's going to happen
so i was the only person that was
interested in doing it had been put out
to all the parishes around malden town
and
basically they weren't interested at all
do you want to know
thank you i mean i i think where we are
i think um
mr quel's just sort of gone down this
road and i sort of agreed with him at
the time because it was it seemed the
most efficient way of filling this post
and actually getting some sort of
input from
uh interested counsellors from the
biggest councils either at both end of
the spectrum so we have burnham and
morden but i can see how
the democratic process perhaps isn't
being fulfilled
um
so
i i shall go to
councillor fleming please
thank you chair um i was just going to
disagree with my colleagues um although
it's just a pragmatic solution to
um although i obviously represent
parishes it you know
it doesn't worry me that it's moldentown
and burnham they're the largest
areas in terms of population so
i don't think we should
overthink this thing
thank you
thank you and i think that's pretty much
where we we were both coming from mr
welch myself
um but i'm sure we are
we're up to amending that if we needed
to
up to members um
i finally have to members this is only a
suggestion if members have a different
all i ask is that members take account
of making something workable elc didn't
work
doesn't work that was meant to represent
um
we'd have to go around all the councils
if we're really going to be democratic
then there'd have to be every council
every council would have to go around
each one had the opportunity of
nominating
and then all those nominations would
then need to be determined by by council
for council because it's full council
that actually puts
these nominations on and that to me is
quite cumbersome i understand the theory
i understand that but when it comes down
to practicalities and
we're the officers that have to do it if
i might say
um
then i think it's very cumbersome but if
members want to go down that route of
course we'll do it
so
counsellor none so i propose then that
when there's a vacancy for a parish
representative
an email is sent by the district council
to every parish clerk within the
district
asking for nominations by
a particular deadline date
uh if more than two nominations are
received they're putting a hat
and it's
they're just drawn
if no nominations are received the full
back position is to contact the towns
the two town councils
so we we blanket cover all the parishes
ask for nominations and then
just choose from that randomly
okay so can we take a vote on that
proposal then let's try that all those
in favor
one two three
four and against
one eye
i think that proposal
as an amendment yes please
can you hear me all right
all right mr chairman um
i think a lot of people don't understand
what jsc stands for it's almost like we
need after the jsc brackets board of
inquiry or something like that because
everybody i've spoken to they don't know
what it means so it may need an
explanation of what it is but also don't
forget we've got to have a substitute as
well which it says further down the art
so if you have two one be the main
person the other one connected as a
substitute because at the moment there's
no substitutes of being elected
thank you
very good suggestions and uh
we should actually make that the email
cover
thank you chair are you happy for me to
move on to my second point i most
certainly am thank you
so my second point relates to old
five
in appendix one
now it might just be me i'm getting
confused by this
but the informal resolution appears at
two stages
it appears at stage one
so it can be an informal resolution at
that stage
but if the informal resolution is not
applied it can move on to stage two
and there can be an informal resolution
at stage two
and i don't quite understand that
because it says at stage two
the mo and the ip consider and pursue
possible informal resolution
so they've already decided that there is
no informal resolution but jsc
send it back to say there should be an
informal resolution um does that not
question the decision of the mo
mr quelch yeah i fully understand what
councilman is saying i i follow the
logic
um in relation to
five um paragraph five one of the
options as you write and say counselor
nurna is that
the mo and the iep can rather than
investigate because these are all
alternatives rather than investigate
give an informed attempt an informal
resolution often that yeah sorry
um often that is i'm sorry about that
often that is
like a mediation sort of role which i've
done quite recently in a particular case
um
[Music]
but it may be that at that paragraph
five stage
both of us are of the view no it should
go to investigation but the investigator
may then say the investigation the
result of the investigation may be that
it wasn't as serious as we thought
and that the investigator has brought
out information that makes us then when
it comes back as yes there is a breach
but it's really quite technical it's
really quite minor we might then look at
it and rather than referring it to jsc
which obviously um
um
it is the norm
um
we might both decide no this is really
quite a minor bridge and we think we can
now go back to the informal resolution
based on the investigation report
the thing about investigations is they
are obviously uncover a lot more than we
would do at our initial assessment stage
i'm grateful for that clarification so
should it really read then under breach
stage two
uh
following investigation
um it's considered that this is not a
serious matter that needs referring to
jsc
jim let me just say i think i think
that's helpful
a helpful clarification
i would think you just need to say
following investigation considering
pursuing formal resolution
that in itself means that it's not going
to jsc but i think that's a helpful
clarification chair
happy with that if my colleagues are
chair
second yeah could we just go to
councillor siddhl please before we do
that
yeah so on this particular point this is
where an issue arose last year so we had
the investigation
into the joint standards committee's
behavior
last january and that was a formal
investigation that had a formal report
and the interesting thing about this and
it still says the same in this document
which i'm really really not happy about
so on node breach we have a report
for js members free information okay
that was but there's no so there's no
breach
but jesse gets a report no okay
we go to breach
and the monetary also need a person
consider
and pursue possible informal resolution
but nothing comes to jsc
and that's what happened last year in an
investigation where the findings and
investigation were that the individuals
had brought the council into disrepute
but because the monitoring officer
decided that it was just an informal
approach that
nothing came back to jsc
i spent weeks writing to the monitoring
officer about this because i was so
unhappy and it was it wasn't the
monitoring officer internally that made
that decision it was an external
monitoring officer and when i looked at
our process
this is where our process there's a huge
hole in it
because there's there's a formal
investigation there's an informal
resolution but we don't get told about
it
yeah so so but if there's no breach we
do get told about it
that's just ridiculous absolutely
ridiculous
on some of these matters
i would be interested and absolutely if
you have some views
thank you very much
um
i've listened to what members are saying
it
it's absolutely right that um if there
is an investigation it can throw up
quite a different outcome
to what one might originally have
thought when looking at the complaint
that's brought before you
how that is reported
is really a matter for yourselves as a
committee whether you want to see
absolutely everything which i would
strongly suggest you don't because um
you'll just be snowed under with a lot
of um tedious information basically or
whether things need to be selected as to
their significance and that's not always
clear
and it sometimes would be a matter of
judgment for the monitoring officer to
decide when something should come to
this committee and when an informal
resolution
can be
done to the benefit overall of the
council and that's where an element of
judgment comes in
but um
i think you know there
i'm not unhappy with the amendments that
have been put forward i think it helps
to tighten things up when i first read
this
um i thought yes this is
making things a lot clearer and a lot
tighter for for members but obviously
it's up for members to determine how
they assess their um complaints process
thank you
thank you very much
council
settle would like to come back
yes please
so it's interesting that the independent
person says that yeah we'd be snow on so
i don't think we'll be slow down and i
think it's really really important that
that in that anything where there has
been a form of inf formal investigation
that it does come to gas
to say that a report comes to us
for information when there's been no
breach
and then
not to us when there has been a breach
it's just nonsense so that the breach
thing if there is an informal resolution
there still has to be a report that
comes to joint standards the same as if
there's no breach
so that has to change so the monitoring
officers can consider a pursuit and
possible informal resolution
once that has been done
a report comes to joyous joint standards
for information
it's got to say the same
thank you counselor none would you like
to was that a proposition from
councillors
councillor said is that a proposition
i'll second that
opposition and uh so could you repeat
that proposition for berna please so in
in the circumstances where there is a
breach the monitoring officer and the
independent person consider and pursue a
possible informal resolution
the report is then presented to jsc for
information
okay so we've had that seconded so could
i ask a show of hands if you agree with
that and we seem to be in agreement with
that one
can i suggest chairman that the wording
therefore that we'll put in is following
that decision of the committee following
investigation following councillor
nunn's helpful addition mmoip consider
and pursue possible informal
resolution with a report to jsc
afterwards
are we happy with that working
that would be excellent thank you very
much
um
if we're all happy on that point i shall
go back to councillor nun who has his
third point
thank you and it's my final point chad
thank you very much um so my third point
um
refers to the footnote which is the
public interest test
i found that particularly helpful
because i was
talking to mr quelch some time ago about
a decision-making framework
i think what's really important with
joint standards committee and we've had
evidence of this both ways
is that we focus very much on
objectivity
and we're quite clinical in our approach
and ironically enough we don't make it
personal
even though it is actually a personal
issue
in employment there are tests that can
be applied
so with the disciplinary case for
example there's a case of the virtual
test
in a redundancy situation it's the polky
test
and i believe that with joint standards
committee we can turn this public
interest test
into a decision-making framework
and that would in itself
act as
an aid memoir for this committee and its
members
and would also
produce an audit trail
for future reference
so i'm just wondering what mr quelch
feels about turning those bullet points
in they might need to be amended and
beefed up slightly
but turning those uh those bullet points
under the public interest test into a
decision-making framework that has
headings
that has um
and evident evidence and whether that
amounts to
a breach thank you
mr crouch
um
i think that personally is too limiting
for the committee because i think what
council and is talking about is when the
committee comes to make a decision on a
report
and then impose a sanction
um
i'm trying to put that into some real
rigorous
almost um
[Music]
transactional
formula
i think
the committee have to the committee
there could be something in here that
says the committee need to consider
these public interest tests for stop
in deciding on sanctions obviously not
in relation to a breach because you're
looking at evidence there you're you've
got a report from an investigator he's
done all his research he's interviewed
everybody comes back and he says yay or
nay there's a bridge you've got to
decide whether you agree with his
reasoning or not
when it comes to a sanction i think
that's what councillor
um nun is probably referring to the
second stage of jsc's process of
deciding what sanction to impose
um
you could certainly
i think it goes without saying in a way
that you're going to apply a
proportionate
sanction
to
the nature of the bridge
so i i actually i don't know that that
would be personally particularly helpful
it's helpful for
for me and the independent person when
we come to decide whether there should
be a formal investigation or not
is in other words is it worthy of it is
it
is it a politically motivated tip for
tat
we should consider those matters but i
think when it comes to the sanction
stage i think you just need freedom and
in your decision letter
or when you make a resolution that
reasoning will come out as to why you
think a sanction
that particular sanction should be
imposed
counselling okay um i just thought it
would be helpful really because i mean
you know the questions could be for
example
is this councillor still in office has
there been a fair investigation
undertaken
is there evidence that there is a breach
has this been done for personal gain
is it politically motivated has the
subject
been been harmed in any way
emotionally or otherwise
i just think it's useful to work through
not a checklist but something that helps
focus the mind otherwise it becomes just
a big grey blob
that we have to kind of work through and
and try and understand
chair if i may just um just
i mean what we could do if if members
agree with councillor now what we could
do
is
put in something
an additional
paragraph under stage two
that if
the jsc determined so it says you know
the the the second bullet point under
breach jfc here in 27th as a breach of
the code and to impose any sanctions
um
then could put in in determining
sanctions
the committee will have regard to the
public interest test
which obviously is already footnoted
thank you could i just quickly go to
councillor civil please
thank you chairman uh i agree with the
monitoring office i think
the thing about those those that public
interest test
for
the investigation to have started those
things yeah we know that one of those
things the man in the street would have
said that it's not particularly good
and
from my experience of being on gsc for
the last two years
most of that comes out in the report
that's presented to us anyway
so it comes out in terms of the evidence
and it comes out in terms of
investigation
so i i think
and in terms of the recommendations of
the possible sanctions so i think
i think those things that that cancer
nun is talking about tend to be
in those in the recommendations that are
put to jsc and they're the sort of
things that
the monitoring officer has put in his
report anyway for it to get to that
stage so
i can see what councilman is saying but
i don't see and actually see the need
for it because it's in the report anyway
that's my personal view counseling would
you like to come back
uh well i don't change my view on that
thank you chair um but if we're not
going to put it in the procedure it will
be in my head
in future hearings thank you
thank you very much
so in other words happy to leave it
thank you thank you
so there we are so uh councillor siddal
thank you german so i'm i'm going back
to uh that's all i've got several points
that i want but i'm going to go back to
point
uh
where are we point
one let's say point what we say
composition uh on on page
13
and point a
in terms of their the composition the
the crucial thing in terms of the
composition is that no political group
has a majority as well that needs to be
stipulated it is part of the terms of
reference of this committee based on the
work that we did last year in changing
the competition and composition and
changing the terms of reference it's
really important though in terms of in
terms of competition it is stated
that no political group will have a
majority on this committee
that's my first point okay so that's
politically balanced is what we're
saying basically i think
the the composition of this is is that
yeah that is there is there isn't like
there isn't a group that has a majority
so there are four independents and then
there are four others made from other
political groups the fact that we
haven't got a full committee today but
so what we don't want to happen which is
what happened in the past is we do not
want a political group to have more
numbers than another group and that's
why that motion went to full council
last year to ensure
that that never happens
and that's my point i think it needs to
be written there
councillor mayers uh yeah and i think
this is in reference to uh hearings um
rather than necessarily this sort of
forum where we are all here um to to
debate uh and i would like to second
that if that is a proposal
thank you can i just of course
just a legal point here um
um and chairman just uh while i'm
speaking um i just wonder whether
the independent person can have freedom
just to raise his hands and make points
whenever he wants to about any
particular matter absolutely
um
just on the point of political balance
um
you can only exclude the political
balance rules
if every single member on the council
agrees with that
and
you can't say for you can't say for
example let's just say there's one group
in the future that has a majority
within the council
you can't take away the right from that
group
to have a majority on jsc unless
unless
there is no member
in the council or 31 does not descend
okay councillor siddal
and that's what we agreed at full
council last year
uh chairman that only applied for one
municipal year and can only apply for
one municipal year
i thought it was it changed the
constitution it changed the terms of
reference of this committee
a resolution of that nature only applies
for one year
so therefore i think we need to bring a
resolution
councillor fleming
thank you chair yes because at the
moment we have four independents two
conservatives and two
non-aligned so it's actually
one group does have
a majority
but we don't have
an overall majority we don't have five
and that's what i'm trying to say it's
it's yeah it's really really important
that one group does not have
the
the numbers to out vote
in in terms of and that's that yeah i'm
in the largest group and i'm saying that
the largest group shouldn't have five
it would be wrong for us to have five
because that would make this committee
too political
that's my that's my personal view that
was the whole point of that joining
standards motion if necessary i will
bring that motion back to full council
again
um
and and i will ensure that not just for
one municipal year that it goes in the
constitution forever
okay mr cruz
yeah i understand what a council of
civil is trying to achieve
but you can't do that legally you just
can't do that you cannot take you cannot
override the political balance
legislation like that and that's why the
regulations i think it's regulation 15
or 16 says
that
these rules can
do not apply
where every where there is no descent
that they shouldn't apply and it's a
double negative
um
[Music]
and so if one members
i can only be for a year because all the
time there's a reconstitution
of each committee at stat annual
and so if you have one member that says
i don't agree that is it political
balance provisions must apply by
operation of law so you you can't write
into the constitution something that
overrides an act of parliament
councillor
so you can do it for a year
yes but you can't do it
we can't change our constitution
to say
so so it's interesting i i don't i
didn't understand the technology
technicalities of it last year but the
technicalities of it last year
um
at
the full council meeting in november
there was some things that happened
which i didn't really fully understand
because it was really really technical
in terms of our constitution
but
again there was things that our
constitution says one thing in the legal
situation says another thing
so surely surely if we make out yet and
we've been told though our constitution
is law so surely we can create a law for
this council that this council abides by
um
yeah
i'm trying to make to all i'm trying to
make sure is this committee is fair
that's that's my that's what i'm aiming
to do is to try and make this committee
as fair as possible okay mr mitchell
thank you chairman i think
i fully understand what you're saying
but uh that legislate that part you know
that political balance is that with
elsewhere in the constitution rather
than here this just just states that
we've got the committee and that's so
many people to um local council
representatives one independent person i
don't think you need to be saying that
this is no that's politically balanced
or anything like that that is for
another part of the constitution
and um you know otherwise you'll be
constantly amending this there's
different councils come in changing the
how they set things up you know how they
now start referring to all sorts of
other
like uh parts of your constitution
saying things get overlooked and before
you know where you are you're in quite a
mess i would strongly suggest that we
you know by all means
operate with political
balance you as the council wishes but in
terms of what's in front of us here it
can just be left alone
thank you councillor mayors
uh yeah mr um thank you mr chairman i'm
now confused as to whether or not there
was a
100 um agreement at full council
um
to the political balance anyway
so it may be
wasn't a lawful
resolution that we made in the first
place because i cannot believe that
there was 31 of us that actually all
agreed unequivocably
to it because that
doesn't happen
um
and that was never actually made clear
that if
there was one person that dissented
um for whatever reason that that the
political balance issue
could not be um addressed in the way
that it was addressed in the last
municipal year
um
bit concerned now thank you
councillor siddal
uh it was a virtual meeting and if you
remember
okay
just before the start of the meeting
uh the leader of the council used a
particular phrase
at that particular meeting
and
therefore when it came to that
vote
because if they'd not voted for or
abstained
they would then have been guilty of
something else
so it did it was voted through
unanimously
so but but yeah so
okay counsellor nun well i think mr
mitchell makes a good point that um you
know it's an interesting debate but it
doesn't really need to be in the
appendix does it
uh it needs to be
wider than that it needs to be an issue
that's discussed uh you know in in
relation to our constitution uh rather
than the the um procedure for joint
standards committee
so perhaps not to be
debated and included
today but perhaps something that we
could pass on
through mr quelch
to have discussed at full council thank
you that's a very good idea councillor
siddal would you like to come back
uh yeah i'm happy i'm happy with that
excellent so i will move on to my next
point
chairman
before you ask me to do something that
isn't lawful
um i can't do that i'm sorry i'm the
monitoring officer and you're asking me
to do something that i've already told
you you can't do
um so i have to say
i cannot do what you ask me to do
um if at
annual
a member wants to raise a motion
that political balance does not apply to
jsc for that municipal year
and there is no dissent fine
fine for that particular
municipal year political balance doesn't
have to apply to joint standards
committee but i can't
i cannot bring a report back to council
asking for a change to the constitution
elsewhere as mr mitchell helpfully
mentioned
when that's not lawful
okay thank you councillor none yes and
what mr quotes just said is exactly what
i meant yeah excellent thank you
councillor stilts
thank you mr chairman i'm actually
jumping down what has raised that point
i was going to bring up on
h it says three voting members shall
make the quorum well my concern is three
main but maintenance is not pretty
balanced is it
things we've just been saying about it
so we've got three members makes the
quorum
um unless we have conundrum uh
chairman just to clarify
who attends isn't the subject of
political balance it's who sits on the
committee that is the subject of
political balance so if a if you've got
a politically balanced
committee that's politically balanced in
terms of its composition if a member
doesn't turn up
and um then
yeah that's a matter for that member but
they have the right to attend that's the
point
and have chosen not to okay
thank you i think we're sort of caught
no we're not there we are councillors
i'm happy with that one but i can't move
on to my next point of course
so point d i think eight years is far
too long
um i really really don't think that a an
independent person can serve for more
than one one period of four years and
and i think that should change so the
person should be appointed for a period
of four years full stop
and concert two terms of office
interesting point councillor mayors
i'm in agreement with that
and would if that is a proposal i would
second that proposal so we have a
proposal that the independent person can
have a term no longer than four years
and that's the proposal
and we have a second us so can we have a
show of hands on that who
agrees to and against
three
three
great so i'm afraid that proposal has
not been carried
um
are we
are we coming back counselor siddal i i
i am coming back uh i'm coming on to um
page
14
um
and
it's where are we
trying to remember
okay say
point three all claims complaints will
be so it's uh point uh item
number 4.3
all complaints will be annoyed and the
accounts have complained of notified
within four of working days the leaders
of the council will be notified of all
complaints against district councillors
and generally kept advised
i would also like to see that the leader
of their political group will also be
notified
anyone
what page will be so it's on page 14 uh
so and it's the last point on that page
so it's it's
uh code of conduct complaint process
written summary stage one point three it
says at the last last sentence the
leaders accounts will be notified of all
complaints against district councils and
journey captain advised
and the lead is that if the leader of
the political group is different to the
leader of the council they will also be
notified and kept informed
the relevant to that counselor
yes if it's a counsellor involved who
sat perhaps
is a conservative
and the leader of the council is an
independent then therefore the leader of
the conservative group is kept informed
cancer fleming
i just wanted to ask councillor siddhel
to what purpose is
what how does that it's for freedom of
information yeah it seems unfair to me
that
the leader of the council would get
informed about a counselor's conduct or
an investigation but the group that that
person is in
isn't the leader of that group isn't
informed about it at all
again it seems to me unfair
um i'd like mr quelch's opinion on
whether it's for me i think it's a
privacy matter i mean why why would
i just
i think that
and maybe you you might want to hear
from the independent person on that as
well after me
i think it is
i can understand why
councillor siddal says what he says i i
do understand that
but
the whole point about these
complaints and any potential
investigation is up until the point that
they have been completely investigated
and then normally they come out in
public normally
um
i think
confidentiality is really important
and there is the least opportunity for
for members to be talking about an issue
and the problem is that if a group
leader that's more people i'm not saying
a group leader wouldn't be
wouldn't be careful with that
information but i think it's just more
people
more members that know about it and
i think i take
councillor fleming's point that there is
a confidentiality issue here
okay could i just go to councillor maze
please
yeah thank you mr chairman um yeah if
you read a bit further down on stage one
um it says um point
the second one down refer to political
group leader for action m-o-i-p to to
reconsider if no action taken
um
well there seems to be a um
the opportunity to
tell the leader but that sort of
is that a yes or is that a no or is that
well we might do or we might not do it
to me there's a bit of ambiguity here as
to
we either do or we don't
and it shouldn't be just uh well we will
refer to the leader the political group
leader
um
if no action is being taken we're going
to tell them anyway
so therefore the confidentiality thing
has gone completely which mr quelch was
just referring to thank you mr crump uh
it's it's thank you well i
i understand why you think it's
contradictory um i would suggest you it
isn't
it isn't contradictory
because
it's
at
paragraph five the mo and the ip have
decided they don't want to go down the
formal investigation route but they
think there may be an issue that the
group group leader can help on in
dealing with the particular issue now i
have to say i've never used that
particular option but it is there
if and maybe there is an issue of party
discipline or group discipline that the
mo and ip think is is is better than a
formal investigation so at that
particular point
you could say confidentiality can be
breached in the interest of resolving
the complaint but only at that
particular point if the um
mo and ip feel that a formal
investigation is more appropriate then
my view is that confidentiality is
really important at that particular
point
councillor siddhls yes please
too many screens
but surely if you're going to do that
you need the permission of the person to
complain against
yeah they might not want their political
leader to be told about it so there's
not going to be investigation
and you you've decided that there isn't
anything formal going to happen
then then why should yeah why should
that the group politically be told told
at all
that yeah that person might say i want
them to know
you're breaching my confidentiality
monitoring officer
so we again we've got it both ways you
can't have it both ways
[Music]
[Music]
this is a process that has been
determined by council
that that that the monitoring officer
and the ip have to follow it's it's
quite prescriptive
um it's detailed
um
and
in an analysis i i can see a situation
where the both of us will be in a
situation where we feel
i think that there is a valid complaint
here but it will be better dealt with at
a group stage now a part of that may be
me contacting the the counselor that's
the subject of the complaint so i've
never done this before
um and saying look we can either go down
the formal investigation route or we
could submit this to your group leader
for him or her to resolve
are you happy for that to happen
um i've been in a situation
that's similar where i've asked a member
if they're happy for an informal
resolution
to take place
rather than informal investigation and
they jumped at the opportunity rather
than a formal investigation
so
i i i personally don't see any
contradiction in this process i don't
know whether what chair whether the
independent person has a view
hopefully he does
i don't want to appear too much uh
not independent but i'd have to agree
with with mr quilch
their
confidentiality is important someone has
a complaint made against them
it was me you'd be mortified to be your
first reaction and i'm sure everybody in
in this room that would be your first
reaction that would be one of uh
this can't be right how can i behave
like that but also you might not want
anyone to know that at the same time you
are part of a group
a political group
and
you would
tell
the group leader anyway irrespective of
what's in the constitution what's in the
process that this is happening and that
may well happen but there could be
reasons you don't want to do that you
might have issues in your group anyway
so i can see it it's important not to to
spread the the news widely and also
you know the leader of the council does
need to know if we've got if our things
you know happening if there's patterns
emerging if we've got a lot of petty
complaints which seem to be targeted
against a particular member
things little patterns like that which
which you know
wouldn't we wouldn't want to become
would form part of an investigation in
the in the longer term but in the short
term could be relatively easily resolved
and so
i think in the early stages certainly
before anything gets to form an
investigation there does need to be
as many opportunities to
resolve things and that those
opportunities narrow down the minute
names names are mentioned people become
identified then things closed down so i
can see the importance of just keeping
things fluid and one way of doing that
is just
making sure that circulation of
whoever's in um been named and
complained about is quite also the
complainant as well may not wish to be
particularly known at this stage there
may be issues that uh
there may be
somebody may require a great deal of
courage to put a complaint forward and
be quite worried about the outcome of
that so they would need some degree of
confidentiality and help at the same
time and so for all the reasons mr
crouch much more eloquently put forward
i would hope okay thank you thank you
very much councillor siddal please
thanks chairman uh so i i i i will now
go back to point three there before we
do could i just go to council and none
just like to comment yes i'm
um sure i think we're getting a bit
bogged down now really because under old
five bullet two
that hasn't been changed
there's no red on it
it's already in the procedure
so we're debating something that hasn't
been amended
the second thing is that
in any with any procedure
unless it's indecent or unlawful
if the body concerned adopts the
procedure they're bound by it
including their members
so with a procedure that's adopted that
says you wear a red hat on monday
you're agreeing you're wearing a red hat
on monday and if you don't wear the red
hat you're in breach of your own
procedure
so this procedure makes it clear that
there will be a reference to the
political group leader which we as a as
a body as a council have agreed to
so
i i don't think there's an issue with
confidentiality or breach in any
in that respect at all
and as mr quelch has already said and
we've heard him say
he's never used it
or rarely
so i don't really think we need to
debate it no and i think i think we have
debated it and i think we can move on
from this is that
are we happy to to move on to
oh sorry councillor may sorry
uh yeah thank you mr chairman i actually
think that um this particular bullet
point is in the wrong place
um if you're gonna take no further
action that's the end of the matter
you're done with it
uh
if there is going to be any form of
informal resolution i think at that
stage is when um and certainly listening
to what mr quelch was saying
that would be the more appropriate place
for referral to
a political group leader to get a
resolution
in an informal situation
i think if there is no
further action the decision is to take
no further action it's no further action
end of story
you you can't then have a second bite of
the cherry and that is implying
implying that you could have a second
bite of the cherry
not that mr quelch has ever used it
i just feel that maybe that bullet point
is just in the wrong place
thank you
thank you
so i'm i'm happy to yeah if that needs
to change and then i will support
councilman on that in terms of informing
the the political leaders that yeah it
doesn't seem to be a consensus behind
that so i'm happy to to move from that
particular point but i would support
councillor may's
proposition to
change the order of things
counselor none but i understand what
counselor may say but that's a shopping
list isn't it under five that you don't
do all of those things
you do
one of those things
you know you either take no further
action or you feel it serious enough to
refer to the political leader or you
look at an informal resolution or you
refer it to the police it's not you
don't do all those things it's their
options
that's the maze sorry if i could come
back it actually says to reconsider if
no action taken so you you are you're
having two bites at the cherry the same
cherry um i'm happy to leave the the
sentence in
but it needs moving and it isn't just a
shopping list
you know
there's always options and we need to
make it absolutely clear to all our
members that um you know if no further
action is going to be taken there isn't
then well actually i'm going to to go to
um you know you can't sanction me you
can't do anything but i'm going to talk
to the group leader anyway
i'm not sure that that is actually a
fair way of doing business and i would
prefer it and i still put back onto the
table to be voted against that's fine um
that that particular sentence actually
goes underneath informal resolution at
which time it will be absolutely
appropriate that a a group leader was
involved uh at the agreement of um the
the com um
the member that's being complained about
as as mr quelch has suggested i know mr
quelch also suggested that this had
never been used um and let's hope that
it won't be
thank you
i'll second that
number would you just like to come back
just to come back sorry i don't wish to
extend the debate but you know it's
saying here it's not saying there's no
case to answer it's saying there is a
case to answer so we're going to refer
it to the political group leader for
them to sort it out amongst themselves
but if they decide they're not going to
do that
then we have no alternative but
to reconsider
what action needs to be taken
isn't that what it means
yes
but we still have a proposal on the
table which has been seconded
so um
and that's to move that bullet point
could could i could i come back
because it actually forms part of the
informal resolution element it doesn't
form part of the no further action
element
that's why i'm suggesting that it's
moved under the informal resolution
bullet point thank you thank you
mr clothing
i i admit a little confusion here i'm
sorry
um
um
i i really don't quite know how to
answer because i am a little confused
about what's being proposed i mean
is the proposal that
this second bullet point becomes a part
of the third bullet point that's just
one of the
okay
um
so it's not a separate bullet point in
itself you don't want it separated from
informal resolution
is the i proposal that
if the political group leader doesn't
deal with it or doesn't want to deal
with it because it might be referred to
a group that says i don't want to deal
with it um
[Music]
the the
bit in parenthesis remains
yeah
okay so oh
well if i say all it i don't mean all is
i'm not being disrespect but
all it is is that we're just
putting
we're moving the second bullet point
into informal resolution okay i
understand then that's amazing yes yes
okay
into it
so
are we second
okay so can we have a show of hands
one two
three against
two so that is moved okay so can i move
to my next point please
please do
my next point is point four
and uh which is just above what we've
been talking about perhaps this is on
page fifteen page fifteen yeah point
four right at the top yep
uh if the subject counselor declines to
cooperate with the mo without good
reason then the sorry
if it declines to operate with the with
them at a good reason then the ma move
director consult within the person
how long
does the mo wait
for this cooperation
so what is there a time period that then
the mo says okay i've not had a reply
they're not cooperating is that five
days is it one day is it ten days is it
fifteen days so counselor are we asking
for a time yes please
in there okay what's reasonable
i'm open to ideas
um
again i would prefer there isn't some
prescription in there
i think you can
if i may say leave that to your mo and i
p well i know it talks about the mma
going directly to the upper you could
leave that to your mo
to decide in the situation
when that time for example you might be
in a situation where a councillor says
no where am i going to talk to you about
this full stop but okay straight away
you know there may be a situation where
the counsellor
is
is under some pressure and there's a set
of circumstances that you realize is a
bit more complex
now that paragraph five talks about
there there is a control there
afterwards
um
in the the 15 working days from receipt
of complaint would kick in
so that in to some extent would control
it so
paragraph 4 said mo will seek further
information as required within 10
working days of receipt if subject
counsellor declines to cooperate
um
[Music]
then go straight to the independent but
there is this
next control
in time
that within fifth i'm proposing within
15 working days a conclusion has to be
reached as to what will be done with the
complaint in other words nobody's
hanging around neither the complainant
nor the member
about what what's the way forward with
this complaint so i think that's where
the control is okay thank you mr crouch
i think that's like throwing a regular
ad to a ball really saying we're going
to leave it to the monitoring officer um
so i shall
go to uh mr councillor siddal please uh
yeah so if we if if the 0.4 could be
amended to if the subject counter claims
to cooperate within the 15 days noted
below
then i'm happy with that
yeah all 15 days within within 0.5 of
this
if i might just say that it has to be
the case because 0.5 already says that
okay it's got
the the absolute deadline and these are
deadlines i mean i i try and operate
well before these dead these are
absolute deadlines
and if with that if by the 15 working
days i haven't received anything i've
got to go to the independent person and
and find a way forward okay so i i now
have another point to make which
affected me dramatically last year in
terms of the investigation that i the
complaint i put into the council and the
complaint went to formal investigation
and was going and we had an external
investigator look at that informal
investigation
the person that the complaint was
against did not cooperate for about
three months during that formal
investigation
so
that then delayed the report so the the
report took
approximately nine months to get to this
committee because the monitoring officer
kept waiting for a response waiting for
a response the person did not respond as
a result of that that also affected me
raising a complaint with the police
so when i did raise the complaint with
the police
after the joint standard committee had
met i had gone over the six month period
to raise a harassment complaint to the
to the police about that individual so
in terms of the formal investigation
when that can when that's conducted
there are no time scales stipulated
there and that is unacceptable
council amazed please oh yeah thank you
mr chairman um
i i see no problem with actually putting
in uh the 15 days as it then cross
references the paragraph below and that
that that's a a proposal i
think we should actually
look at and just quickly go to council
fleming if i may i'm in favor of some
time scales perhaps
slightly more generous than 15 days
so yeah the unfortunate paragraph below
stipulates 15 days so
the proposal
uh yeah the proposal is is literally
it's a cross-reference proposal which is
that um the the um
sorry i forgot my glasses uh
that the 15 days is the period of time
um
that is allowed
for
the uh counsellor to
come back to the monitoring officer
because
you can't tie a council somebody down to
15 days if for example if it's come
seriously there needs to be you need
that
to keep that
well that's if that's already in there
if that's
mr krabs
and in fact that's that actually
happened to me recently uh there was a
counsellor um and he had had some
serious illness
and he didn't feel in a position to
respond because he was so sick so that
as has actually happened to me
so would we be happy with the proposal
for the 15 days time frames going there
with leaving in with good reason
unless there's good reason
yeah yes mr chairman yeah
okay and we've had that seconded uh
councillor
we're gonna vote on that yep exactly so
we've had it seconded so we're going to
vote on that so can i have a show of
hands for those in agreement
and i think that's fairly unanimous
thank you
councillor siddall
again i know
so so i now move to
the this stage
uh
1.5 formal investigation there has to be
a time limit for how long that fall
investigation takes because at the
moment
a counsellor cannot respond
to the investigator and not respond to
the investigator not respond to the
investigator and there is there is
nothing that says
now your time is up
yeah they are breaching the code of
conduct by not responding to
the monitoring officer but there is
nothing that says
where how long do we leave this for so
we've got time limits now at the
beginning but during the formal
investigation if the if the person who
the complainant against decides not to
respond not to acknowledge anything
then we just wait
yeah and they can be as uncooperative as
they want to and as i said last year
that was three months
three months
and after those three months were up the
individual still had not responded to
the monitoring officer
which is it's unacceptable so we're now
it's really good we're getting these
time scales at the beginning of the
process but we've got no time scales in
the middle of the process
and again is there a proposal of time
frame would you 15
for a debate but would that be 15 days
that sort of time frame
throwing that open there is anyone any
ideas
counselor maze
it's just a clarification can councillor
sedal please refer us to the
page and paragraph
yeah so if you it's on page 15
and we're on stage
one of the process so under point five
and so it says for you so
the final bullet point is it's in red
because there's lots of
obscuring but the final point there is
formal investigation so the formal
investigations now takes place
either internally or externally but
there is nothing that specifies
how long that formal investigation will
take there's nothing that specifies
that the complainant has a time limit so
the time limit at the beginning to
respond to the the 15 days within reason
but during the formal investigation
there is no time limit for them to
respond to the monitoring officer
so they can sit there for several months
that's happened last year and not
respond and there's nothing we can do
about it so there has to be an
element that says okay during this fall
investigation if they do not respond
within two months during the informal
investigation process or by the end of
the formal investigation or once the
investigator has conducted their
investigation if they haven't responded
then then that's that it then moves on
to stage two
which it doesn't stipulate that at the
moment we have to wait and wait for an
unspecified amount of time before we
move to stage two
cancer fleming
thank you chad i just wanted to ask mr
quelch sort of in his mind what he felt
was a reasonable
time for someone to respond
i think what we're doing here is
and i i know the the particular matter
that councillor siddha is referring to
and he's absolutely right there was
non-cooperation
this was with an external investigator
um
i can see the advantages of um the time
and the time the question is how long
you know you look at the different types
of investigations i can see an
investigation i've done an investigation
two weeks
personally
but the one
that's been referred to in the past
about the conduct of this committee
that was extremely complex
and involved it was an external
investigator
and it involved him interviewing
at least 15 people at some
degree of depth the transcripts were
extremely long we're talking a report
that must have gone into 150 pages or
something like that it was immensely
complex
and it's almost like saying to the
police when someone makes an allegation
you have two weeks or three weeks to
complete your investigations well that
might be so for a petty theft
you might be able to deal with that call
the person and they pleaded guilty
that's it bang
straight off to the cps
but you might have an extremely complex
fraud case that takes three years to
investigate
um
i've been in fraud cases and and trials
can last six months
um so
that's the problem with setting a time
thank you councilman i mean it might not
satisfy uh councillor siddill this but
you know could we put in brackets next
to the the red bullet form an
investigation
that this commences within x days
and is concluded in a timely fashion
councillor syddell
i i i think
we're getting close to coming up with a
with a a
something that would make this a a
formal investigation work
my view it's forming for investigation
starts
if the
complainant does not respond to the
investigator within one month
then they're
then
of the of contact i don't know um then
that then that is considered that they
do not have any input or they do not
want to contribute to the investigation
i'm trying to i'm trying to
put it around those those words
but there needs to be something that
says we don't wait if the complainant
doesn't want to respond
then then
and deliberately doesn't respond and
deliberately holds up the investigation
then therefore there needs to be a time
limit so if if the investor if the if
the complainer has not responded to the
investigator by the time of the
conclusion of their investigation
then it's considered they do not want to
participate
in my experience with procedures or hr
procedures you can end up hanging
yourself with your own procedure
and that's why there needs to be an
element of flexibility in it because you
can never tell
all of the circumstances in advance
and i think using words like timely
works
but if you start saying and if they
don't respond by x this is going to
happen
it will go horribly wrong
anyone
mr mitchell yes please
i think the the difficulty we have in
that
made a very good point
the difficulty becomes that there's
almost a black hole once an
investigation starts because
it disappears off the horizon lots of
things go on they don't know what's
going on and then something comes back
and is presented to you as far as i can
work out on this stage
this committee has not seen this
investigation yet is not aware of it as
a committee it is uh something that mr
croche and i have taken away and playing
with
um
so
it could be ages before this committee
is even aware of it
and
there's no way
that i think you can accommodate that
other than
as counselor nuns said by making
reference to a timely manner and being
sure when the complaint is opened and
referral is made to the uh
the the council being complained about
that you know i think council said
always makes a point that you do need to
respond to this or there comes a point
when we just go ahead without what we
assume you've got no no input to put on
this and that that's that and that that
point must come but i wouldn't want to
put a time scale on it because things
could happen in between but there will
need to come a point where
this needs to be drawn to conclusion and
brought to this committee for
for a decision
and that decision may well be well we
need to give this counselor a chance to
uh
to address the point but
that opportunity has been made and
i think one of the difficulties you have
just making more general point
this committee doesn't seem to have any
scheduled meetings it meets
am i right that's correct whether that's
something you've looked at
um
that can be cancelled in advance maybe
but at least it's an opportunity for
updates on various things to be brought
to members
if there have been issues
uh that you wouldn't have in a in the
current system but that's that's a wider
issue for another day i think thank you
councillors
so i'm not sure
yes
yes
[Laughter]
thank you mr chairman um
from a complainant's perspective
timely manner is
open-ended it could be six weeks
it could be six months it could be six
years
from the person that is being complained
about
don't matter
but i'm i'm not certain that we are
being balanced enough
in um looking at both sides and being
fair to both sides
this at the moment appears to be
well you know if if the
um
the the counselor who's who's got the
complaint against them doesn't make
contact
in a timely manner
well there's no definition of timely
manner
um
and it can drag on and you you leave the
pers the other person that is
suffering
because they've brought that complaint
and it's no you know small thing to
bring a complaint against another
counsellor uh it's not something that
one takes lightly
uh you're left in limbo land and
potentially that could be
for six months because that might be
what somebody deems as timely and all
i'm suggesting is that that initial bit
where there is
non-cooperation and that's the bit
that's the nub of this i think i really
think that's the nub of this um that we
do put a time period of say eight weeks
or two two calendar months something
like that i think that is perfectly
reasonable
for um a counsellor to get their act
together and decide if they are going to
cooperate with an investigation or not
um i think to leave it in limbo and then
at least the
um the person that is um
subject to to it is is
not left without some time frames that
they can cope with
thank you councilman i think we've just
sort of established though that in the
wording if we put a time frame then we
sort of we have the goal post of how
long the investigation will go for where
a timely matter
actually gives us
some leverage to say well we've given
you we've given you time
and and now the investigation has got to
this point or however we are with the
investigation and now it you know we
we've we've given you time where we if
we put a time
element on this
then we as we've been explained an
investigation could take an awful long
time or it could take a short time so i
think we
counseling
so i haven't got a dictionary with me
but i think you'll find that timely
actually means without undue delay
uh so
my proposition
under five and the red formal
investigation that's underlined says
formal investigation commences within
five days and is concluded in a timely
manner that's my proposition and i'm
going to take that proposition and i'm
going to ask for a seconder
okay so could i have a show of hands for
agreement or we have
and so i'm going to move that proposal
i feel short-changed
okay i mean i can i just say there is
there is one part of this which i'm not
particularly happy with and that's to do
and that's in stage one and that's the
informative bit
where it suggests that um
some of the the somebody who's making a
complaint um
can be anonymous and
i don't feel that should be the case i
think i think the the complainant should
be made known and i think whoever's
making the complaint should be made
known
okay so i should go to councillor mays
uh yeah thank you mr chairman um it it
does say here that um they will disclose
the identity
um
but
unless there's very very good reason um
so i i sort of
i understand what you're trying to say
but i'm not sure that
there is any movement in that you it's
if someone was um
you made a complaint
and it was um it was so serious that it
required police investigation then
um i'm not sure that
i don't know where i'm going with this
one my point is
if if we were dealing in
on a different level if we were doing
with
with rape or
child abuse or something like that
i can understand it but i do i do think
that one of our problems is that we have
been bombarded by people who find it
very
easy to make complaints against other
people and actually you know i think the
fact that they are allowed to to be
anonymous
or would be
withhold their identity because of very
good reasons and i can't really think of
any really very good reason why a
counselor against another counselor or
anyone in this chamber in this complaint
system would would need
would need that kind of protection
council amazed yeah can i just come back
um in that case um
the the good reason part needs to be
removed
gentlemen
chairman am i just
make a comment on that
don't forget there may be a complaint
made by somebody
that
says there's a breach of the code in
that a counsellor is using their
position unfairly to get unfair
advantage
according to this at the moment within
five working days of that complaint
being made
i need to inform the
counsellor
the subject of the complaint
about the complaint and who has made it
now
we don't get to refer to the police
until later on which i think is
councillor may's point actually
um
and then it's too late so if it really
is a point where there has been some
um fraud
that would then be where the mo and ip
would say we think this ought to go to
the fraud squad in chelmsford
for for considerations to whether they
want now
a member of the public it may be a
member of the public that discloses that
and they're very nervous disposition
and if i tell them i'm sorry i can't
take your complaint if you will not
allow me to disclose something quite
serious may not be uncovered that may
ultimately go to the police at stage at
paragraph five
so
i think we could be in some difficulties
on that point chairman
i mean
i'll throw that open
of course
not every complainant is a member of the
council
some are just
you know members of the public who are
going to be quite nervous about bringing
a complaint like this and wouldn't want
their details perhaps released they
might live two doors down the road for
example and not have a very good
personal relationship for example there
could be good reason and i would suggest
that
you either leave it or
if you wanted to say that counsellors
should not be anonymous that's that's a
matter for yourselves but um
i'd say there are other people that make
complaints no and i take you on i mean
again speaking from personal experience
having having had complaints made
against myself at one point and the the
the complainers were actually kept
you know their identity was um
was kept away
and i found that very unjust because
if somebody makes a complaint against
you i think you have the right to know
what that complaint is within a
reasonable period of time which we have
done and who is making the complaint
and i think if we were dealing with as i
say other issues if we're a court of law
i can fully understand that but actually
the kind of issues we're dealing with
i really don't understand why if
somebody's making a complaint they
should have the option having their
identity
um withheld
is my view
uh councillors
[Music]
um
so i think it's a legal minefield this
one
because if somebody makes a complaint
and says to mr quelch but you must not
disclose that i've made the complaint
what's mr quelch going to do
even in employment uh there's a there's
an issue of
uh protection and and and minimity in
terms of whistle-blowing processes and
procedures um and you know there are
the points already been made that this
is not necessarily a counsellor
complaining could be a member of the
general public and they might genuinely
feel intimidated
and frightened
so i you know i just think we've got to
tread carefully with this if the default
position is that it's our usual practice
to
notify the complainant that's fine
but under certain circumstances i think
we we might
we might have to withhold that really
okay i'm willing to agree with that i
think i think the wording probably
should be left
if we're all in agreement
any more for any more
so
we've had the report and i'd like to
thank mr quelch for a very comprehensive
report and uh
and a bit of a grilling today
but i think we've come to quite a
satisfactory sort of end result so i
would now like to
[Music]
go to the recommendation which is on
page nine
and with all our new changes
i would like to
the recommendation is that that the
changes in appendix one to the articles
for the standard array
arrangements and especially to the
complaints
process be approved
do
so the changes that we've agreed in
appendix one go to full council
okay agreed
and we can agree that by a cent by the
seams of it
okay thank you very much
phew so i should go to item number six
any other items of business that the
chairman decides are urgent well thank
goodness i have nothing of any urgency
whatsoever
um and
so i should go to item seven which is to
are we done mr chairman
sorry if i may um
right item six um
i think it's correct that the decision
of
excepting here right that's better right
uh correcting the decision with regards
to a hearing by jsc
has to be confirmed by morgan district
council phil
steaming up now
for council
um
okay if the political balance was as
before the recent two
2019 elections
um
well basically we we had um a hearing um
and it came up it went to someone
straight away came in and said i don't
agree with it it was a
the
um her remarks was already written out
printed out for her to read what are we
referring to though here sorry well the
thing is um
so let's say the balance was as pre the
elections no but i is is this an agenda
item or is it oh it's on past 16 uh part
six which i thought was any other
business
or is that just to you
yeah that's just just for the chair i'm
afraid yeah okay thanks okay thank you
um
so i shall
now close this meeting at
thank you very much